oh there's a humpback whale right here
the humpback whales are going over to
the killers
oh wow the humpback's right in the
middle of it
two humpback whales just came out of
nowhere
that can't be a coincidence that the
humpbacks turned up now
you must be going over to try and
disrupt the hunt I mean that has been
recorded before humpback whales trying
to disrupt killer whale hunts
killer whales sometimes take humpback
whale calves
and scientists believe this drives the
adults to try and disrupt any killer
whale hunt that they come across
yeah but today the b1s won't go hungry
one of the killer whales
Hot Wheels
that is just an unbelievable Wildlife
interaction
wave washing killer whales hunting seals
in Antarctica is outrageous enough of a
thing to see but to then see two
humpback whales come in try and disrupt
the hunt
and then the killer whales take the body
of the seal towards the humpbacks as if
to say you didn't stop us look what we
did
my mind is completely blown